welcome to the Microsoft translator hub
video on project and community
management in this video you'll learn
how to create a new project and invite
new users let's take a look at how to
create a new project in the upper
right-hand corner of the page click on
the project's tab and then select create
project you'll notice that several of
the fields here are required first give
your project a unique meaningful name it
is not necessary to mention the
languages within the title though you
may find that useful if you wish write a
description as to what the project
covers or add any notes you want to
associate with the project this is
particularly useful if there are
multiple project owners then select the
source and target languages the source
language is the language you're
translating from and the target language
is the language or translating two
together these are referred to as a
language pair finally you may select the
category from the category list
drop-down to further classify your
project and distinguish it from other
projects that have the same language
bear this enables you to make a
domain-specific translation system that
is more targeted and accurate within a
particular domain in the category
descriptor box you can add any
additional information to further refine
the category for instance if you select
medicine you might want to add a
particular topic such as toxicology or
Pediatrics if you selected sports you
might want to add tennis or sucker once
you're satisfied with the information
click the Create project button once the
project is successfully created you will
be given the option to either add users
or set up training the training process
will be covered in a separate video so
let's focus on adding users to the
project on the invite member page fill
in the forms for name and email
addresses select the role for this
invitation co-owner or reviewer co-owner
is a
manager role that helps guide the
project a reviewer reviews and suggests
better translation for your translation
system both of these roles are trusted
relationships an additional role which
is not specified is your community
members who are only allowed to provide
feedback but cannot define new projects
or start a training session a default
mail is generated depending on the role
you have selected for these individuals
the message body on the invite form
lists all the activities that a co-owner
or reviewer is authorized to do you can
personalize the message if you like then
when you're ready just hit the send
invitation button you'll need to repeat
this process for each invitation once
you've added members you can change
their roles or remove them as needed
here on the manage members page which is
available from the community menu now
that you've created a new project and
invited users let's take a look at the
other items in the project menu to
manage an existing project click on the
project tab in the upper right-hand
corner and then select manage projects
the project's page will show you an
overview of your projects including
language pair category quality score
using the blue metric deployment status
and the last modified date if you wish
you can delete a project by clicking on
the remove project link click the
project name to view more information
about a specific project the project
details page will show you more
information about training runs
associated with this project for
instance if it was successful or not the
blue score as a quality metric number of
aligned sentences for training tuning
and testing monolingual sentence count
and whether or not that training used
the Microsoft model you can click on any
individual training for more details
about that specific training Microsoft
translator have might not yet support
the language you'd like to use in your
project however you can request a new
language for your project from the
project menu or the
create new project page select request
new language fill in the form giving us
the name of the language as well as
additional information such as regions
where it is used dialects etc then click
the submit button you'll receive an
email from Microsoft verifying your
request for a new language this
concludes this video for additional
information check out the other videos
in our help section as well as the
in-depth documentation on the site